considering the balancing actor has to
pull off Avengers infinity war is pretty
great the movie has a gargantuan task of
advancing and paying off ten years of
storytelling and directors Jonah Anthony
Russo handled the assignment well that
said infinity war is a first movie in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I might
leave casual viewers behind if you
haven't been keeping up with the
franchise the film contains a number of
moments that may leave viewers
scratching their heads rather than fully
engrossed after 20 movies in this series
it's easy to lose a few and even if you
saw them when they came out how long has
it been since then so if you left the
theater with questions don't worry we're
here to clear up some of those muddier
moments for you if you haven't seen the
movie you should prepare for some
spoilers in your head
the mind stone implanted in the forehead
of the vision is the second Infinity
stone we've seen the MCU we see it in
the scepter that Loki wields Stern the
Avengers but it's changed hands so many
times since then there's easy to forget
how it ended up in the powerful Android
in the first place here's a recap after
Loki is defeated in the Avengers shield
confiscates a scepter supposedly for
safekeeping unfortunately the
organization turns out to be rife of
undercover Hydra agents who smuggle the
scepter into the hands of their boss
Wolfgang von Strucker
von Strucker uses the stones to perform
experiments on humans and give them
powers which is how Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch come to bay during the
events of age of Ultron the heroes
managed to get the scepter back from von
Strucker during a raid on his compound I
a man realises that can be used to power
his version of Ultron unfortunately
Ultron goes rogue and uses a mine stone
to power up a new body for himself the
hero steal both the stone and the robot
body and then combine the two to bring
their new teammates of the vision to
life a most unexpected cameo infinity
war wouldn't be a Marvel movie without
an out of nowhere cameo from Stan Lee a
deep cut Marvel Comics character or
someone else in the movie series that
you didn't count on showing up sometimes
I played for laughs like Bruce Banner
and Captain America popping up in Iron
Man 3 and Thor the dark world but
Avengers infinity war features a cameo
from a character we were all certain
with seen the last of Red Skull
his appearance to Kimora and the fan
oohs and the planets Vermeer is an
awesome moment but it's also one that
some viewers couldn't help but respond
with an
Red Skull is a villain of 2011's a First
Avenger where he's obsessed with using
the tesseract to fuel hydras plans of
world domination his downfall comes in
the film's climax when he picks up the
cube which begins to envelop him in some
awesome energy just like in Raiders of
the Lost Ark with a screamin and
explosion he shot out into space with a
blue laser beam seemingly never to
return it's the last we see of the
character until his surprise return in
infinity war his tampering of the space
stone in the tesseract led to his
imprisonment on the distant planet where
he's cursed to guard the soul stone
never able to possess its power or to
leave Joe and Anthony Russo have since
discussed the scenes inclusion of Red
Skull explaining it felt like there was
more credibility than just a random
character as his ambiguous fate in the
First Avenger demonstrates the red
skulls we emergence on vol Mia wasn't
completely random it just might have
felt that way
sibling rivalry you'd think a father
would love his children equally but then
again that isn't exactly father of the
year even the daughter he claims to love
Gamora is sacrificed by Thanos so he can
wield the sole stone and she was
kidnapped to begin with exactly top tier
barren zone it begs the question as to
why phonos doesn't seem to have the same
sort of affection for his other
daughters at nebula it can also lead to
some confusion as to why Gamora had to
be the sacrifice and for Mia when Thanos
already had nebula imprisoned on his
ship wouldn't she be a worthy sacrifice
for the stone as well it's established
and the guardians of the galaxy films
the Thanos raises nebula and Gamora as
competitors rather than siblings pitting
them against one another and battles
time after time Gamora constantly wins
and every time she does Thanos mutilates
nebula replacing one of her limbs or
organs of cybernetic appendages to
improve her skills as a warrior
nonetheless she never defeats Gamora
there's a Darwinian side the Thanos
defines nebula to be inferior to Kimora
his masterpiece she's he ultimate
warrior and he gives himself the credit
for making her that way in his own sick
way he truly loves Gamora in a way he
can never love nebula not that it worked
out that well for her paging Captain
Marvel the post-credits scene is a
hallmark of the MCU and for the most
part they expand the universe and set up
future films infinity wars post-credits
scene is no different it pulls away from
the battle in Wakanda to show the
effects of Thanos erasing half of all
life on Earth Nick Fury Maria Hill
realize what's going on and fury pages
someone as he disintegrates who could he
be reaching out at a time like this and
what does a little red and blue symbol
on his pager mean the moment can be a
bit confusing for anybody not already
familiar with the character Captain
Marvel who's getting her own solo movie
in March 2019 more not too much is known
about how the character will fit into
Avengers 4 we do know that her solo film
takes place in the 90s well before the
events of most MCU films have seen so
far we also know a pre eye patch Nick
Fury will be involved knowing all this
gives the scene a clearer context fury
recognizes that something horrible is
happening and calls on an old friend we
haven't met yet
Captain Marvel to save the day where
she's been and what she can do to help
in his fights that's a question not even
the comic books can answer
Tony's chess problems I am on three
closes with Tony Stark stepping down as
Iron Man and destroying all of his suits
in the process he also undergoes
invasive surgery to remove the shrapnel
in his chest allowing him to finally get
rid of the arc reactor has kept him
alive since the first Ironman
however age of Ultron opens of Tony and
the Iron Man suit and back at a full
time by the time the film is over
furthermore at the beginning of infinity
war we see that he's actually still
toting around an arc reactor on his
chest
so why as Tony explains to the
long-suffering Pepper Potts the
enclosure spotted in infinity war isn't
actually an arc reactor of the saw that
was slowly poisoning him in Iron Man 2
rather it's an enclosure for nanotech
basically a storage space for his newest
Iron Man suit to reside he still clearly
got a problem of giving up the Iron Man
identity but at least he stopped
poisoning himself with a radioactive
gunk
where's Wong dr. strange and his ally
Wong are introduced pretty spectacularly
in infinity Wars first massive fight
sequence when that duo joined Iron Man
and spider-man to take on Thanos's
henchman Cole obsidian and ebony more
the two sorcerers are a highlights of
the first act and Wong even gets his own
character poster so why does he vanish
after the fight and not to be seen again
for the rest of the film the answer lies
in Doctor Strange and is very briefly
alluded to an infinity war it all comes
down to Doctor Strange and Wong's home
the sanctum sanctorum part of a network
of sanctums manned by other sorcerers it
helps generate a shield against evil
otherworldly forces there must always be
a sorcerer in each sanctum as Doctor
Strange is going to be
off-planet with Iron Man and spider-man
Wong has left to stand guard and keep
the planet safe we still don't know if
he survives Thanos is purged but we can
at least rest assured that he kept her
safe from non Thanos threats for the
rest of the Avengers were trying to stop
the big purple guy who had the Infinity
Gauntlet the Infinity stones and the
gauntlet built to bear them have been in
play in the MCU since its earliest days
even if only in the form of brief cameos
one or six stones rest in the Infinity
Gauntlet the user is granted complete
control over the universe the gauntlet
actually appears in the franchise before
any of the stones doe limbs - briefly in
Odin's trophy room in Thor however
according to infinity war
Thanos gets to go on it from each Rey a
dwarf and master weapons forger how does
this make sense it's quite simple really
the Infinity Gauntlet in Asgard was
counterfeits this is revealed very
quickly in thor ragnarok when hello
ransacks the trophy room fake fake as it
turns out the real gauntlet is with
Thanos who had each rebuild him a real
one as the dwarf describes it might be a
bit confusing if you missed Heather's
line in Ragnarok so let's not even talk
about that third gauntlet and e3 studio
Drax is vengeance Drax the destroyer a
character who is largely served as comic
relief over the course of his last two
cinematic outings has one of the most
tragic backstories in the MCU as the
guardians of the galaxy movies establish
his wife and daughter are victims of the
wrath of the Kree terrorists Ronan the
accuser the title of destroyer was
earned thanks to the murderous rampage
he's been on since losing them
it does make one wonder though why he
holds such a grudge against Thanos if
Ronan is the one who murdered his family
he is why after Ronan is defeated in
guardians of the galaxy
Drax learns that the Kree Warrior has
been working for Thanos all along
which means Santos is ultimately
responsible for the death of Drax as
family
Drax Emery focuses his thirst for
vengeance on the mad Titan and carries
that rage into infinity war what did it
cost
most MCU films are pretty
straightforward but this changes for a
moment in Avengers infinity war after
Thanos fulfills his goal and wipes out
half of all life with the snap of his
fingers the film cuts the Thanos and
Gamora in an unknown world between
gomorrah's younger
parents and the inexplicable change in
location this segment is a bit unclear
is it all in fan oasis head
why is Gomorrah a child what does it
mean what we're seeing in the moment has
been confirmed to be a realm existing
inside the soul stone in the comics
displays the soul world and it's
populated by the souls of those absorbed
by the soul gem while that's yet to be
an explanation for the soul world and
the MCU we at least know that's where
Thanos his conversation with Gamora
takes place and she appears as a child
because it's how he still envisions her
this may go on to be a crucial scene at
once Avengers 4 arrives
maybe ant-man in the wasp or shrink
inside the soul stone to burst everyone
else if they're actually in there or
maybe Captain Marvel will just beat down
Thanos until he lets everyone go where
they'll find out in 2019 thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love today
[Music]